j'adorais le métier de mes parents
botaniste j'adorais me ronger les
princes les essences de fleurs
je rêvais de fabriquer des potions
magiques
j'écoute toujours on vient de faire une
découverte faramineuses les plantes sont
capable de grandir façon géo et dégager
une énergie dingue quand on en rate
afrique tout dans culture ong au les
bénéfices mandera
l'état les messieurs acquis
c'est une révolution grâce à t-il m la
faim dans le monde est en voie de
disparition
derrière tout cela
cette aventure est dangereuse la plante
valable a envahi tous les continents
mais je ne peux vraiment pas les fêtards
tu sais quoi d asperges gros bêta
l'essai nature libre